hi my name is Albert Brooks and I feel
confused that I'm asked to do something
I was asked 40 years ago by some dis
jockey on
khj Dawn in the
morning uh and I I guess nothing's ever
changed so I'm confused about being
Conan O'Brien's
friend oh my
God we bought the rights from that disc
joogy hi I'm Rob Riner and I feel uh
almost honored yes to be Conan Conan
O'Brien's that's uh that's so close to
being a real just a real statement from
both of you um there's no way around
this so I'll get it out of the way uh uh
I've done how many of these have I done
Adam
520 how many this is a uh
it's a big day for me I'm totally uh in
love with both of you guys and your
incredible body of work and so the fact
that you're here talking to me is a huge
deal and that's pretty much all the time
we have I think we should wrap it up
there because there's these are two men
that don't want to be complimented
especially uh especially Albert I have a
hard time with it that's Barry Sanders I
want to be compliment you want
to you're incredible Albert what can I
say um you know I think the same Albert
yeah okay I have to say uh um there's a
lot to talk about here I wanted to start
because it just happened we just lost uh
Norman Le I know you guys both knew this
man very well and for you uh Rob he was
like a second dad he he was I mean I'm
very lucky that I had two role models in
my life that I uh I could look up to and
I I learned from I mean I met Norman
when I was a little kid and he uh you
know he tells a story I don't remember
it but he tells me that I was uh
teaching his daughter I was playing with
his daughter who was eight years old we
were both eight and we were playing
Jacks and I was teaching her how to play
giving of the rules to Jacks and
apparently I was doing it in a funny way
I didn't know and he told my father he
said you know your kid is really funny
and and my dad said really uh that
Sullen child of mine he can't be that
funny so Norman was the first guy to rec
can I say how times have changed because
that's how long ago it was that the
thing was your kid is so funny playing
Jacks
today nothing said about a kid with a
little girl is ever
good but wait a minute wait a minute if
you call your dad it's a very creepy com
yeah yeah but Albert we were both eight
I wasn't like 24 and she was eight you
were you were Advanced for your
age and your line for much of your adult
life is do you want to play Jack used to
say you're old enough to be
cancelled you know um it's uh I you know
one of the things about these really
funny people that occurs to me sometimes
is I well first of all Norman was was he
101 101 absolutely unbelievable and of
course your father Carl lived
9898 and I was at some event and uh this
is maybe two years ago and Norman was
talking and he talked about this
longevity thing with commedians and he
said I swear to God people always ask us
it's something about laughing all the
time yes he said him wait a minute Henry
Kissinger yeah have you been
he he was very funny was very funny very
funny he laughed every day I saw him
once at The
Improv and how did he do he did that
same Vietnam bit yeah did it get any
laughs I told him the peblo was was real
they didn't believe laugh laugh and then
he did audience work have you yes I was
going to say his crowd work was
spectacular where you from but where you
from you call that the sweater you have
papers so the point is yeah if you laugh
every day you live a very long time I
think that's no no no maybe also think
of people we know contemporaries that
are no longer with us at left I don't
think it's any of that I think it's
lucky yeah okay well I tried to say a
sweet positive thing yeah Albert took me
out at the knees Albert put a damper on
it yeah
yeah